[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau numéro de sept huit
sociétés votre rendez vous hebdomadaire
où nous parlons des sujets qui font
l'actualité
en 2000 la loi sru solidarité
renouvellement urbain impose aux
communes de plus de 1500 habitants à
disposer de 25 % de logements sociaux
une nouvelle loi assouplit la
réglementation sans ôter le taux de 25%
mais l'objectif de ce taux est il
réalisable on en parle avec nos invités
françois morton bonsoir
vous êtes le maire de guyancourt et
arnaud bas gagné bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes adjoint au maire délégué à
l'urbanisme pour la commune de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines alors avant de
développer avec vous ce sujet je vous
propose qu'on fasse le point sur cette
fameuse loi 3ds elle a été adoptée le 9
février c'est cette loi qui assouplit la
loi sru sur les logements sociaux et
pour bien la comprendre bixente main
santisteva journalistes de la rédaction
bonjour bonsoir mélanie
pour comprendre justement les
modifications apportées par la loi 3ds
il est important de savoir qui est
éligible par la loi sru vous avez
commencé à en parler mélanie en région
parisienne ce sont les communes d'au
moins 1500 habitants appartenant à une
communauté d'agglomération d'au moins
cinquante mille habitants dont l'une des
villes est supérieure à quinze mille
habitants
assimiler ces conditions est donc
nécessaire pour voir ce qu'entraîne la
loi 3ds dans les faits la loi 3ds rang
permanente l'obligation de créer des
logements sociaux à hauteur de 25% pour
les villes qui sont soumises c'est à
dire qu'il n'ya plus de date précise il
faut atteindre ce quota c'est la règle
cependant l'instauration d'un cms
contrat de mixité sociale permettent aux
communes de prolonger la durée de
rattrapage du contrat non pas jusqu'en
2025 comme initialement prévu mais
désormais jusqu'en 2031
autre facilité il est aujourd'hui
possible de mutualiser les logements
sociaux entre les communes d'une même
agglomération d'une même communauté
d'agglomération cette loi suscite de
nombreuses inquiétudes de la part de la
cgt qui la trouvent trop laxiste envers
les oui en dessous des 25 % de logements
sociaux requis quant à la clcv elle
craint qu'une seule commune soit amené à
concentrer le travail des autres villes
de son agglomération entraînant ainsi
moins de mixité sociale cependant l'état
garantit que ces délais alternatives
offertes par la loi 3ds soit créé pour
donner plus de temps aux communes de
s'adapter mais dans les facettes
obligations à long terme de renforcer le
taux de logements sociaux et de le mener
aux 25 % demandés merci le vicente
menace en titane pour toutes ces
précisions donc on l'a bien compris
c'est un peu de souplesse mais photo
quand même atteindre les 25% à l'aube à
gagner je vais commencer avec vous vous
êtes donc adjoint au maire de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines en 2020 la
commune était en était un peu moins de 5
% de logements sociaux c'est un déficit
de 100 103 logements sociaux cette loi
traduit 3ds est ce que ça soulage un
petit peu la commune déjà pour atteindre
s'auto
oui écoutez c'est vrai que la loi trad
3ds était une loi que nous attendions
depuis notre prise de fonction en
juillet 2000 vabre ça vous arrive et aux
affaires saint-arnoult-en-yvelines en
juillet 2020 le constat est le taux de
logements sociaux était celui que vous
avez vous avez décrit j'irai même plus
loin des logements sociaux qui
constituent l aider quasi 5% sociaux
existait avant l'instauration de la loi
sru ça veut dire que
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines entre 2000 et
2020 d'un produit est conventionné aucun
logement social supplémentaire ce qui
nous a évidemment causé quelques petits
problèmes avec les services de l'état
qui sont garants du respect de la loi et
qui nous ont donc nous sommes carences
et des carences et depuis le 28 décembre
2020 donc c'est un sujet qui occupe le
plus clair de mes journées depuis depuis
notre élection pour essayer de trouver
des solutions et pouvoir tendre vers un
taux qui serait beaucoup plus acceptable
évidemment pour l'état et qui irait dans
le sens de ce que m'ont aussi d'une
certaine façon
les habitants de saint-arnoult qui
souhaite aussi pouvoir se loger c'est
pas toujours possible aujourd'hui
l'offre l'habitat de saint-arnoult est
constitué de
essentiellement de maisons individuelles
ça fait partie des choses qui sont
évidemment également demandée par une
partie de la population ces logements
cette joie donc vous permet de mettre
plus de temps a tonné atteindre ces 25%
mais ça oblige à les atteindre certaines
communes pouvaient jouer un petit peu
sur les dates et attendre que c'est la
date fatidique passe vous allez
continuer à travailler et l'allemande
que vous payez qu'aujourd'hui qui est de
plus de 190 mille euros vous voulez plus
la paye et j'imagine
au delà de la de l'amant de nous allons
payer en 2021 192 1000 euros d'amendé
exactement ce qui représente un petit
peu plus de 66 % de notre budget de
fonctionnement ce qui est ce qui est
considérable
aujourd'hui nous avons besoin
mais des solutions encore une fois
l'état nous demande de faire des efforts
qui d'abord doivent être réalisable vous
dire que en arrivant juillet 2020 je ne
suis pas sûr qu'on soit
en responsabilité en tout cas l'équipe
municipale en place que je représente ce
soir n'a pas la responsabilité de la
situation qui a été l'héritage
finalement de notre élection
quand on arrive en juillet 2001 et qu'on
nous explique que la loi sru s'achève le
31 décembre 2025 et qu'il faut produire
500 de logements comme vous l'avez
rappelé alors même que nous avons depuis
toujours 123 logements sociaux c'est
quelque chose d' irréaliste et
irréalisable
c'est tout l'intérêt de cette loi de 3ds
qui remet une dose de réalisme dans la
loi et pour des villes comme comme la
nôtre qui avons beaucoup de retard c'est
aussi un moyen d'y parvenir dans des
conditions qui doivent rester des
conditions de qualité de construction de
programmation et d'intégration de ces de
ces nouveaux logements dans notre ville
qui reste une ville
très rural et pour lesquels les fonciers
ne sont pas non plus illimité voilà une
somme de choses qui sont des contraintes
réelles de nos territoires qui ne sont
pas forcément compatibles autant que
certaines autres villes avec cette loi
sru pour autant nous avons décidé nous
faisons l'ensemble de ce que nous
pouvons faire pour pouvoir tend encore
une fois vers une amélioration
significative en tout cas de la
situation telle que vous l'avez rappelé
alors il ya des communes qui ont atteint
ce tome 2 25% voire beaucoup plus
françois marteau à guyancourt c'est 50%
c'est un travail sur de longues années
oui sur de longues décennies devrais je
dire effectivement alors merci de ma vie
tu es sur cette question madame ok vous
le savez j'y réponds toujours
favorablement comme l'ont fait mes
prédécesseurs parce que cette question
du logement est une question sérieuse
c'est probablement le la première
dimension du bien vivre pour une
personne et je crois qu'il faut la
traiter avec le sérieux qu'il mérite
alors effectivement effectivement c'est
une question de delon de long terme mes
prédécesseurs ont toujours eu
effectivement ce souci de permettre à
tout le monde je dis bien tout le monde
à toutes les bourses toutes les
ressources de pouvoir vivre à guyancourt
donc ça passe effectivement par
par une répartition lorsque nous
construisions et nous continuons à
construire des logements sur lui en
cours parce que c'est nécessaire d'avoir
toujours une part à parité 2-2 locatif
social
peut-être marquant sur votre commune
c'est que vous continuez à construire à
il y a une résidence qui a été livré par
résidence yvelines et sane 15 logements
sociaux en centre-ville il a le futur
quartier des savoirs 2000 logements dont
25 en pourcent logements sociaux ce qui
pousse la mairie a continué ses
difficultés à accéder au logement même
privatif en région parisienne avec des
loyers parfois très élevés
ce qui nous pousse à continuer c'est
c'est le besoin assez le besoin
identifié c'est la volonté politique de
le faire encore une fois je le rappelle
toujours parce que j'ai le alors avec un
peu de lassitude je dois vous dire mais
je le rappelle ce jour près de 70 % des
franciliens sont éligibles au logement
social ça c'est une réalité c'est un
indicateur qui paraît tous les ans est
donc finalement beaucoup ne tiennent pas
compte voilà donc c'est un besoin nous
considérons effectivement qu'une ville
comme lui en cours qui est très
attractive doit permettre à tout le
monde de venir s'y loger alors si
effectivement vous parlez des 25% au de
locatif social qui seront dans le
nouveau quartier des savoirs oui mais il
y aussi 25% de l'accession aidée c'est à
dire que ce soit aussi des nouveaux
produits qui permettent aussi aux
classes moyennes par exemple qui
pourrait avoir tendance à quitter notre
région parce que le prix du mètre carré
très cher en accession libre de pouvoir
rester sur notre ville oui il ya
certaines communes comme l'excès sous
voies qui ont vu le préfet mettre fin de
manière anticipée aux arrêtés de carence
en précisant les clayes-sous-bois est
toujours de la 24% les 25% devrait être
avec la construction de trois cent
soixante logements d'ici la fin de la
décennie
vous l'avez dit monsieur banny à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines
l'arrêté de carence il était prononcée
en décembre 2020 vous avez de nombreux
projets actuellement en cours est ce que
vous espérez la levée de cette carence
ou votre taux de 5% va encore vous vous
vous obliger à payer 7 notamment c'est à
l'ombre
pour être pour réactualiser les chiffres
parce que ce que vous indiquez sont
effectivement les chiffres du moment de
notre de notre arrêté car en sus
redescendre 2020 nous avons cela dit
entre temps depuis donc le relever
l'inventaire du 1er janvier 2021 50
logements supplémentaires sont venus s'y
ajouter donc on était parti à grand
chose on était là 123 le chiffre exact à
date et 273 sociaux + 55 logements
sociaux qui sont en cours de
construction qui devraient être livrés
entre l'été et l'automne
deux donc c'est vraiment un sujet
aujourd'hui qui sera bientôt d'actualité
et le taux de logement social va donc
bondir si je puis dire va doubler
en 18 mois et atteindre à peu près 10%
est toujours très loin évidemment des
25% vous l'avez dit nous avons beaucoup
de projets qui sont des projets encore
une fois je suis totalement d'accord
avec ce qu'a dit monsieur morton pour
moi l'habitat c'est quelque chose
d'essentiel dans le cadre de vie et la
qualité de vie de
que nous devons finalement une certaine
façon à nos habitants c'est des choses
que nous souhaitons réfléchir encore une
fois nous souhaitons intégrer et
intégrer des logements de façon générale
les logements sociaux sont pour nous
évidemment une obligation mais nous
souhaitons malgré tout continuer à
construire des programmes équilibrée
comme l'a dit monsieur morton
l'equilibre de 50 % logement social est
une volonté politique que nous voulons
suivre aujourd'hui nous voulons tendre
vers 50 % de logements sociaux sur les
différents programmes en cours donc
c'est une façon qui prendra du temps
c'est ce que nous reproche encore l'état
si je puis dire puisque l'état nous dit
si vous faisiez des programmes à 100 %
de logements sociaux vous pourriez
finalement comblé le déficit beaucoup
plus rapidement ce qui est vrai mais
pour nous ça n'est pas la bonne façon
d'intégrer ces nouveaux logements et ses
nouveaux arrivants dans notre dans notre
ville qui reste une ville rurale je les
dis qui n'a pas du tout la même chance
de certaines autres villes notamment en
ce qui concerne
l'accessibilité et l'accès aux
transports notamment il faut savoir que
saint-arnoult avant d'être carences et a
été soutenu à la fois par rambouillet
territoire par le préfet la sous
préfecture avant de rambouillet le
préfet des yvelines ainsi que le préfet
d'ile-de-france pour être exemptées de
ces obligations et ses rues en raison
des problématiques de transport tout le
monde nous a soutenus jusqu'à
la présentation devant la commission
nationale sru qui de façon un peu
systématique et d'après ce qu'on nous en
a dit de façon politique a décidé de ne
pas suivre l'avis général qui était de
dire que saint-arnoult n'avait pas les
prérequis nécessaires pour être obliger
ses rues à hauteur de 25% voilà sont des
choses qui ont été
défendues par nos prédécesseurs je crois
qu'il y avait une grande partie de vrai
dans tout ça au delà de la qualité ou la
répartition des logements pour moi ce
qui est important c'est aussi permettre
et donner la possibilité aux habitants
de façon élargie à nos 6000 habitants
aujourd'hui de pouvoir vivre dans un
endroit où ils peuvent vivre de façon
générale pas simplement dormir ne veut
pas être une ville dortoir on aimerait
pouvoir associer à ces créations de
nouveaux logements d emploi les offres
d'emploi et pour toutes ces choses
l'état qui en même temps nous d'y
augmenter le nombre de logements et
d'habitants nous dit les dotations de
l'état vont baisser et en même temps on
nous dit pour une raison que nous
prenons tout à fait que nous soutenons à
100% qui est l'environnement et la
préservation de l'environnement on nous
dit on va vous empêcher d'une certaine
façon de créer par exemple des emplois
et d'étendre vos zones d'activités en
tout cas c'est un chemin de croix si
vous voulez c'est toutes ces choses que
nous aimerions faire évoluer en même
temps au delà de l'activité de la
création d'emplois il faut mettre à
niveau et dimensionner correctement les
équipements puis c'est notre
responsabilité première toutes ces
choses ne se font pas en trois ans quoi
qu'on en dise quelle que soit la loi
encore une fois l'état n'a rien fait en
20 ans à saint-arnoult avant de durcir
le ton en 2020 il était évident pour
nous qu'on ne pourrait pas régler la
situation sur les cinq prochaines années
donc la loi 3 3ds est la bienvenue pour
nous accompagner et j'espère très
sincèrement que nous aurons par le biais
de petites villes de demain nous sommes
fiers d'être lauréat avec notre voisin
la ville d'ablis nous sommes lauréats
du programme petite ville de demain dans
lequel l'état veut nous donner les
moyens d'une certaine façon
de faire évoluer la ville pour se mettre
un petit peu à niveau pour accueillir de
la meilleure des façons les futurs
arrivants encore une fois je mélange les
typologies de logement parce que pour
moi le problème elle même que les gens
viennent s'installer à saint-arnoult en
achetant des maisons ou si on a la
chance un jour de pouvoir faire ce que
j'ai compris monsieur morton comme
l'ailé du bail réel solidaire c'est
nouvelle accession à la propriété j'ai
eu un rendez vous pas plus tard que cet
après midi et que le département des
yvelines qui m'explique que du fait que
nous soyons dans une zone b2 c'est un
peu technique mais en gros c'est une
zone qui par définition n'est pas un
territoire tendu qui donne des plafonds
de subventions qui ne nous permettent
pas aujourd'hui d'envisager toutes les
opérations que monsieur morte on
pourrait envisager par exemple sur ces
territoires et notamment l'accès à des
choses un petit peu nouvelle que son ccc
ccc bord et elle solidaire puisque c'est
quelque chose d'assez récent que nous
souhaiterions pouvoir ajouter finalement
à la mixité sociale que nous appelons de
nos voeux en plus des propriétaires que
nous allons déjà nous aurons des
locataires de logements sociaux de
qualité puisque c'est ce à quoi je
m'occupe toute la journée et en même
temps souhaiterions pouvoir les knicks
et d'une certaine façon avec une
troisième typologie de personnes qui
sont les gens qui souhaitent accéder à
la propriété sans avoir les moyens
aujourd'hui d'acheter une maison à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines voilà c'est on
aimerait pouvoir faire toutes ces choses
ce qui leur manque c'est les moyens
d'argent oui justement on ne veut pas
aller je voulais rebondir ex avec
monsieur morton est ce que vous vous
continuez à construire mais on comprend
bien derrière cette loi c 25 % de
logements sociaux il y à tous qui a
équipements ce sont souvent des familles
il ça signifie des écoles et j'imagine
que ça doit ça rentre dans un pack cadre
plus large et on est très loin du simple
logement les simples habitations vous
avez parfaitement raison qui dit
création de logements dits création de
services publics monsieur banier parler
d'emploi aussi c'est toutes ces
questions là qui vont avec mais je
souhaitais aussi revenir sur j'entends
ce que dit monsieur bah gagner pour être
tout à fait franc avec vous on a eu
l'occasion de discuter un peu avant
cette émission il il semble avoir une
vraie volonté politique à saint-arnoult
que de que d'être dans les clous et
j'entends et il est parfaitement normal
que que l'on aide les villes qui
souhaitent effectivement rattraper ce
retard encore une fois qui datent pas
d'aujourd'hui ni d'hier mais qui datent
de longues décennies encore une fois
c'est cette urbanisation c'est pas une
question de temps en aoùt demanda ce
sont des décennies de décision politique
mais ce qu'on voit ce que je voudrais
pointé aussi puisque vous avez vous avez
donné un exemple qui pour moi est
parfaitement frappant les 25% les 25% je
rappelle que c'est un seuil c'est un
minimum ça ne répond pas aux besoins des
franciliens sinon pas que de la région
ile de france c'est simplement un seuil
réglementaire voilà mais encore une fois
il ne répond pas aux besoins et vous
avez cité mon cher collègue philippe
guillen qui est qui siège avec moi dans
l'exécutif de saint quentin en yvelines
effectivement il est à 24 % il va faire
une opération qui va lui permettre
d'être 25% et il a déjà d'ores et déjà
déclaré qu'il n'irait surtout pas plus
loin voilà donc ce sont c'est bien une
histoire de volonté politique et je
crois que le problème vient aussi de la
représentation que certains peuvent
avoir effectivement du logement social
je rappelle que le logement social il
peut être décrit et il est d'ailleurs
très souvent notamment en cette période
on va dire préélectorale par certains
comme étant le diable absolue soyons
très clairs
j'ai entendu quelques propos assez
frappant dans le discours de certains
candidats aux présidentielles
on me parle de zone de non france par
exemple et je sais de quoi on parle
lorsque l'on parle de ces zones là non
la réalité du logement social sur nos
villes ça n'est pas ça ça n'est
absolument pas ça ce sont des jeunes qui
ne parviennent pas à se loger lorsqu'ils
quittent par exemple le foyer familial
ce sont des jeunes actifs
c'est tout ça le locatif social et il
faut évidemment ancrée et continuer à
ancrer après justement êtes beaucoup il
faut pas aller vous parlez de mixité
sociale tous les deux justement souvent
les logements sociaux ont une mauvaise
image sont souvent loin des centres
villes dont pas d'accès
avec les bus notamment celles à l'idée
la première qui me vient vous êtes
beaucoup de communes à construire des
immeubles au moc en mixité il ya des
logements sociaux et l'accession et
emilia de l'accession privé et certains
construisent même au centre-ville à ce
que finalement c'est la solution pour
redorer si le mois le bon l'image de ces
logements sociaux monsieur morton oui
alors l'idée c'est ce qui a été fait
toujours sur lui en course et surtout
surtout surtout de ne pas concentrer les
logements sociaux sur un quartier c'est
une aberration certains ont fait cette
urbanisation à certains moments c'est
une aberration totale l'idée vous
parliez des 50 % de logements sociaux
sur billancourt nous avons en gros cinq
gros quartiers à guyancourt cet
équilibre il est réel dans tous les
quartiers de la ville et et pas
simplement comme on pourrait l'imaginer
par exemple dans le quartier prioritaire
puisque nous avons un quartier
prioritaire dans le cadre des contrats
d'huile est de la politique de la ville
de saint quentin en yvelines non bien
évidemment alors à l'origine oui ces
logements étaient concentrés dans ce
quartier là mais ça n'est évidemment
plus qu'à l'idée c'est bien d'équilibré
équilibrer les territoires
vaguenez l'equilibre vous l'avez aussi
notamment les projets à venir j'ai noté
celui de l'avenue harry griveaux ses 75
12 logements 40 logements sociaux et les
autres ce seront des logements inclusif
qui est aussi une population parfois
oubliés
nous avons à saint-arnoult-en-yvelines
l'histoire récente
de saint-arnoult-en-yvelines et la
volonté de pouvoir développer des
logements à vocation particulière j'ai
envie de dire on avait la précédente
municipalité
n'a pas été au bout d'un projet qui
concerne et une marpa à l'époque donc
c'est pas une maison de retraite mais
c'est c'est une résidence pour personnes
âgées c'est des choses dont le
territoire que nous connaissons bien a
cruellement besoin nous avons une
population qui est vieillissante
saint-arnoult c'est une des plus
vieillissante du sud yvelines nous
n'avons absolument rien pour accueillir
les gens d'un certain âge qui se
retrouvent bien souvent dans une grande
maison qu'elles ont bien du mal à
entretenir qui n'est plus du tout
adaptée finalement
leurs besoins ça je rejoins tout à fait
ce que monsieur morton a dit il ya des
gens beaucoup de gens sont éligibles aux
logements sociaux il ya aussi il faut
vivre avec son temps si je puis dire il
ya aussi des familles recomposées mais
il ya aussi des familles qui se séparent
ou aider des gens qui décident de se
séparer qui voudraient rester sur
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines et qui ne
pourront pas se payer de maisons à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines il faut être
réaliste aujourd'hui nous avons besoin
d'étoffer finalement l'ensemble de ses
offres de logements collectifs de
qualité encore une fois c'est vraiment
notre priorité numéro une sans oublier
par rapport aux pressions de l'état que
nous subissons réellement mais sans
oublier la vocation
de service public et et d'humanité que
nous devons aux gens qui constituent nos
habitants qui puisqu'ils font partie
intégrante de saint-arnoult et
j'aimerais bien pouvoir leur proposer
pour ces gens qui sont soit handicapé
soit un âge avancé donc d'une certaine
façon handicapés en tout cas ne peuvent
plus vivre tout seul ces gens là
seraient éligibles à ce programme de 35
logements qui est en centre-ville vous
parlez de donner des moyens d'intégrer
de façon qualitative ses obligations de
l'état c'est ce que nous faisons à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines l'avenue
griveaux c'est l'hyper centre de
saint-arnoult c'est lé foncier les plus
coûteux la ville il ya investi quatre
cent mille euros encore une fois à la
hauteur de notre petite commune c'est
beaucoup d'argent nous avons investi 400
mille euros en décembre 2022 sous forme
de surcharge foncière pour essayer
d'équilibrer l'opération dont on parle
parce que la zone b2 dont je vous ai
parlé tout à l'heure c'est très dur à
porter si vous voulez en terme financier
c'est très compliqué les promoteurs les
opérateurs les bailleurs sociaux ne se
bat pas pour venir à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines ça il faut
quand même rendre et dire ces choses
beaucoup de beaucoup de gens par le
passé n'ont pas voulu venir face des
opérations parce qu'elle était
économiquement moins intéressante
puisqu'elle pourrait être par exemple de
grands axes exactement pas simplement
met vraiment en terme financier si vous
voulez
les plafonds les subventions
le retour sur investissement d'un
bailleur social comme d'un promoteur
n'est pas le même à saint-arnoult qu'il
peut l'être sur wii en cours donc
aujourd'hui nous avons abondé donc sur
l'opération de l'avenue vevo
l'investissement total de la ville à
date c'est un million et demi d'euros
c'est colossal
on a un budget de fonctionnement de 7
millions d'euros par an pour que
monsieur morton se fasse une idée donc
dire que saint-arnoult-en-yvelines n'a
pas fait d'effort pour c'est pour
essayer de trouver des solutions c'est
faux le résultat est celui que vous avez
rappelé tout à l'heure c'est pas
suffisant est tout à fait conscient de
ça pour autant nous souhaitons discuter
avec l'état c'est ce que nous ont très
souvent et pour l'instant nous avons
l'oreille à la fois de la dtt de l'état
et du département qui nous aident
beaucoup et que je voudrais saluer ici
aujourd'hui nous avons les coudes de ces
gens pourtant vers quelque chose
d'adapté j'ai envie de dire d'adapter on
a besoin de la mine est un film sur la
guinée j'avoue cuper un petit peu je
voulais donner la parole à monsieur
morton pour terminer ce que j'ai
commencé avec vous ça va gagner est ce
que monsieur morton quand pour atteindre
notamment soto et et ne pas vous y
arrêter ce que vous avez été amené à
présenter des terrains aussi peut-être
pour éviter que des logements privés se
construisent alors on est très vigilant
pas nécessairement de le besoin de
présenter encore qu'avec l'agglomération
on peut être amené à le faire bien
évidemment mais pas pas vraiment je
souhaiterais parce que je pense que j'ai
très peu de temps pour pour terminer
dire un petit mot justement sur votre
présentation de la loi 3ds mois elle
m'inquiète en l'occurrence je peux
parfaitement comprendre qu'elle soit
attendue par certains mois elle
m'inquiète par tout ce que vous avez
décrit tout à l'heure par cette
possibilité de mutualiser notamment les
taux de logements sociaux sur un le pci
sur saint quentin en yvelines ça ferait
tout simplement porter ces taux
réglementaire par un tiers des villes et
je vous laisse globalement regarder la
cartographie des villes que cela
concernerait parce que encore une fois
c'est une question politique très
clairement par soi-même dogmatique
soyons très clairs je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure
ce cette possibilité 7 10 difficultés à
faire appliquer la loi sru pendant 20
ans la décision politique de l'assouplir
je trouve ça parfois un peu paradoxal
voilà tout simplement je suis inquiet je
suis inquiet parce que on n'a pas réussi
à le faire dans beaucoup de territoires
par volonté politique qu'est ce qui va
faire que maintenant en prolongeant
effectivement ces délais on va y arriver
alors à part mettre la pression sur
certaines communes et monsieur banier
l'a très bien décrit voilà de manière
peut-être un peu autoritaire d'ailleurs
tel qu'il a pu le décrire sans trop
comprendre pourquoi alors que pour l'un
pour autant que que je puisse le
comprendre ce soir la volonté politique
encore une fois elle est là dans
d'autres communes il n'y a pas cette
volonté politique et je ne vois pas en
quoi la loi 3ds va changer les choses
merci à monsieur morton en effet le
temps le temps file et nous aurions pu
parler encore plus longuement il y a
beaucoup de critères qui concerne ses
lois je remercie mes interlocuteurs de
s'être rendus disponibles ce soir merci
à nos téléspectateurs de nous avoir
suivis c'est bien sûr la fin de ce site
une société on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine et d'ici là bien sûr prenez
soin de vous
[Musique]